I am more than overdue to update this
pitch so I'm gonna talk about the
patreon page for Council of geeks
council geeks is a YouTube channel and
occasionally podcast feed run by me I
talk about all kinds of geeky things
from superheroes to Star Wars Harry
Potter and oh so very much about Doctor
Who I do reviews lists hot takes even
occasionally I'll have a guest on
I'm currently producing four videos a
week to one Doctor Who and two on
whatever may be on my mind be it a movie
I've seen trailer that's come out or you
know if there's just something I kinda
need to rant out of my system cuz yeah
that happens too there are also weekly
live streams and once a month I devote a
video to lgbtq+ representation something
very close to my heart as I am in fact a
part of that community this is not how I
make my living but as the channel
continues to grow and improve thanks to
the subscribers the commenters and the
support of patrons I've been able to
upgrade equipment from the editing
software to the camera I can actually
afford to have somebody who knows what
they're doing make my thumbnails now and
so much more and none of that would be
possible without the support of geeks
like you supporting me and the channel
through patreon actually offers a
variety of benefits even the lowest
level of support you get to see the
docket of videos planned for the
upcoming month and vote on which topic
of a Doctor Who list I'll be doing that
much as that month as well as uh oh boy
I should edit that out but I won't
because that's just kind of how I am and
but up from there rewards will give you
access to things like the council of
geeks discord your name and the credits
at the end of every video a signed
business card official merchandise that
is not for sale in other locations even
a commission review on a topic of your
choosing so take a look around if it
looks like what I do is up your alley
consider supporting me and this channel
because I'm not actually the council the
viewers the commenters the patrons you
are the council I'm just finding the
meetings and I couldn't do it without
[Music]